hi I'm Sarah Goodwin I'm a graduate
student at UCSF and today for I bio
magazine we're talking to dan Barry who
went from being an academic professor in
bioengineering Michigan to doing space
walks and working with the international
space station with NASA and now he runs
his own robotics company in
Massachusetts so thank you for joining
us and today we're talking from the NASA
Ames Research Center in Mountain View
California so you weren't on Survivor I
was wondering what the ultimate
competition yeah what made you decide to
go on Survivor well I just liked the
show I thought as a fun show and I
thought it would be a really interesting
challenge because they have such a great
scheme for changing who's valuable right
so at the beginning you know it's kind
of this teamwork thing and you know the
people that can win the competitions are
valuable and in the middle you you want
to get rid of those people because it
becomes individual competitions and you
want to get rid of the people that are
good at that sort of stuff I'll be but
in the first two phases you still keep
the social people and then in the last
phase you want to get rid of all the
social people because you ultimately
want to be put up against somebody that
everybody hates so that you'll win so
you keep all the people that are really
you know irritating so it's a very good
dynamic to change what characteristics
of an individual are beneficial at the
moment than I came so I thought that was
kind of interesting but mostly it just
looked like it would be fun and I was
actually quite fortunate to get on a
season and be divided into tribes that
ended up with just really very i would
say cooperative and fun people to be
with so I I loved being on spot I really
had a good time even though I didn't
last that long I was kicked off like 60
when my best friend's stabbed in the
back but but it was really fun and I
really enjoyed the experience it sounds
like quite the experiment it was it was
and in fact you know we had a we had a
really good group dynamic going and were
it not for you know a tenth of a second
here they are
you know we would have dominated did you
use any of your science skills and
trying to I know that they have
different kind of I guess games over
yeah they played great compositions I
didn't really use any science i did use
survival training because I built this
kick-ass shelter I mean the best shelter
that's ever been built on Survivor you
know put an app off the ground a nice
waterproof roof and that sort of thing
and I I knew how to make fire which
surprisingly people go on Survivor not
knowing how to do but in the end
actually it was a being unable to solve
a puzzle which which caused my demise so
I have to say and the other thing is of
all the sort of hardships that were
there and there were something and you
don't eat for 12 days that sort of thing
I was surprised to find that the
limiting consumable was dry wood and
that's because you need to have a fire
because you need to boil the water in
order to have enough water to drink and
I guess as a cautionary tale for those
survivors of the future I thought I knew
everything about dehydration I I mean
I'd been through two military survival
camps where the major focus was don't
get dehydrated and so I was making sure
you know i urinated you know twice a day
and I was pinching my skin and checking
and so I thought I was about five pounds
dehydrated because she could only drink
as much as you could boil well I got off
that Island and I had lost in 17 days
I'd lost 33 pounds my god of which about
17 or 18 was water so I regain the water
wave three days but i had no idea how
severely dehydrated it was and then it
went back and looked at the films and
i'm looking at this puzzle i couldn't
solve and I'm like I was completely
confused on that thing because I was
dehydrated so I have my rationalization
as to why I couldn't solve
could you tell us a little bit more
about the importance of cooperation and
advancing knowledge and innovation you
know everybody says cooperation forget
that competitions where it's at right so
keep your cooperation I'm going to go
find the most competitive people and
that's what I'm going to hire for my
company and the example I want to give
you there is from William yer who was a
poultry scientist who did an interesting
experiment which was that you know you
want to get the most eggs out of your
chicken right so there's two approaches
one is you go to the to the hen house
and you pick the chickens that lay the
most eggs right and then you breed those
chickens and you do that for you know
subsequent generations and clearly
you're going to get a chicken that makes
a lot of eggs right so he did that
experiment and after about four
generations what he had was you the
chickens grow in group they nest them in
groups of nine so what he had after four
generations or so was a group of nine
which very quickly became a group of
three because those three murdered the
other six and there were three
featherless chickens because they pluck
the feathers out of each other so he had
picked the most homicidal maniacal
competitive insane chickens and they
were the ones that produce the most eggs
because they would Peck everybody else
and take all the food and lay all the
eggs ok so i was like what how can i put
the tea it was like he built the US
senate or something I mean she sang the
competition isn't always the best
solution and then the alternative
experiment which he also did we should
take the clutches of nine chickens
together whoo together we're lying most
eggs and breed those and that was
successful so so there's many cases
where cooperation completely trumps
competition and this sense of you know
it's all about you know who gets the
perfect score and and who can step on
the other person to succeed that I think
actually is a very weak strategy for
success at least success is measured in
the way that
i think is important
you